[Music]
you
ready let's go oh that was
huge
yeah for those of you that want to know
what we're all about just like this
y'all 10% luck 20% skill 15%
concentrated power of will 5% pleasure
50%
100% Reon to remember the name he
doesn't need his name up in lights he
just wants to be heard whether it's the
beat of the mic he feels so unlike
everybody else alone in spite of the
fact that some people still think that
they know him but him he knows the
code it's not about the salary it's all
about reality and making some noise
making a story making sure his click
stays up that means when he put it down
picking it up is he anyway he never
really talks much never concern status
but still even in Star Struck humble
through opportunities given despite the
fact that many Miss judging cuz he makes
a live from rting RS put it together
himself that the picture connects never
asking for someone's help but to get
some respect he's only focus on what he
wrote his will is beyond reach and now
the SK of this is 20% skill 80% beer be
100% clear cuz Ro was Ill who would have
thought he'd be the one that set the
West in flames and I heard him wreck it
with the crystal met the name of the
game